a court in the Philippines has convicted
a prominent journalist of the crime of
cyber libel Maria race' now faces up to
six years in prison watchdogs have
called the case a serious erosion of
press freedom under president rodrigo
duterte award-winning journalist maria
reza arriving in court in manila to
learn her fate the verdict guilty of
cyber libel for a 2012 article her
website Rattler published linking a
businessman to human trafficking and
drug smuggling Russa once worked for CNN
and holds dual u.s. Philippine
citizenship she says she's been
devastated by the verdict which she sees
as a part of a government campaign
against her and her publication next
year will be my 35th year as a
journalist I began as a reporter in 1986
and I have worked in so many countries
around the world I've been shot at and
threatened but never this kind of death
by a thousand cuts the case was closely
watched as a test of press freedom under
populist president Rodrigo Duterte the
court heard the libel complaint even
though the article in question was
published four months before the
cybercrime law was enacted Russa and
Rattler are not the only prominent
Philippine media to face problems with
the authorities last month one of the
country's leading broadcasters was shut
down
rights groups warned the country is
entering dangerous territory in this
country is that this sense of message
every journalist in the Philippines
particularly the poor ones and the
communities in the provinces that know
you better shut up or you're going to be
next
Russia now faces a prison term of up to
six years in spite of the verdict she
vows not to be silenced and Maria Reza
joins us now from Manila
Maria what went through your mind as the
judge read this guilty verdict against
you it wasn't unexpected if you look at
it in the context of the eight criminal
charge
sighs face I had to post bail eight
times last year just to remain free and
then the slew of attacks against
journalists in that has intensified with
a shutdown of the largest broadcaster
just last month I suppose I walked in
feeling and knowing that there could be
a worst-case scenario that would is even
worse than this one and so when I
listened to it I just I tried hard not
to get angry and then to figure out how
do we continue doing our jobs better
given these attacks are you prepared to
go to jail there you know I think this
is a question I had to confront a while
back because Amal Clooney actually just
pointed out to me that the cumulative
charges the maximum jailed penalty for
all of them is almost a hundred years
and so I think the question is that not
challenging these cases would mean that
I would give up the rights that are
guaranteed in the Constitution not just
freedom of the press but also the rights
of Filipinos to information to hold
power to count now you say this verdict
that's been handed down today as part of
a campaign against you and your your
website rattler calm by president duty
and his government what evidence do you
have for such a campaign actions of the
government part of the reason rattler
came into the crosshairs is because we
continue challenging the number of
deaths in a very brutal drug war the
Commission on Human Rights in the
Philippines estimates months ago that it
was over 27,000 people killed impunity
there and then here you can see that you
know we were under trial today yes the
verdict came out today but the justice
system was also under trial because
what's happened in the last few years is
the weaponization of the law the law
tweaked legal acrobatics used against
journalists perceived critics
opposition's and in that sense that also
follows the kind of
exponential attacks what we called the
propaganda machine on social media so
the narratives of the attacks come out
first on social media and then the law
the weaponization of the law follows
come on eight cases that are all
criminal charges arrest warrants I was
arrested last year and detained you can
see these actions and I think you know
to not take them in a gret in a granular
scale because every single one sounds
almost plausible the attempt to shut
down rattler to revoke our business
license happen in January 2018 and again
if you get lost in the details sure it
sounds plausible but when you look at
the context of it and the context today
is overwhelming it isn't just a chilling
effect on media mm no that's what I
wanted to ask you about what message do
you think that your conviction sends to
other journalists working in the
Philippines I've been a cautionary tale
rattler has been a cautionary tale for
journalists in the Philippines be silent
or you're next that's what the
government is saying the government
wants us to know it's got tremendous
power but it also wants to maintain
veneer of rule of law and as long as it
wants to maintain that veneer we will
continue doing our jobs and pushing back
and challenging these cases in court you
mentioned earlier that you're facing
other charges there are numerous other
charges you could face up to 100 years
in prison for all those what motivates
you to continue your work as a
journalist in the Philippines under
these conditions I think because like
you we know something is happening at
this time period right this is a unique
moment in history we're seeing a rise of
authoritarian populist style leaders
horizon flashes of almost and you're
seeing the attacks on media yeah I don't
think I've lived and I this is my 34th
year I'm gonna be I'm an old journalist
you know and and I've never seen
anything like this I've worked in war
zones I've covered conflicts but this is
is a whole different time period and
I feel like in my country at least we're
standing on the precipice and we must do
all we can to protect press freedom
which protects our democracy Maria thank
you so much for taking time to talk with
us today that was journalist Maria Reza
in Manila